اعلن رئيس حزب الظفر اوميدوس داغ ان حزبه
قرر دعم مرشح تحالف الشعب وزعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوريه التركيه كمالك ليشدار اوغلو في
جوله الاعاده من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه المقرره يوم الاحد المقبل قال في
مؤتمر صحفيا عقده
الاشجار اوغل
و ان الطريقه
الوحيده
هو دعم كريشدار
جمال
اجتمعنا مع السيد كريستار اوغلو واخبرنا
بشكل واضح وصريح عن ضروره عوده اللاجئين
الى اوطانهم وكنا قد تحدثنا عن تفاصيلها
وعن العرض الذي طرحناه في حزب الظفر ان
تكون خلال عام واحد وبطريقه توافق مبادئ
حقوق الانسان لذلك قررنا كحزب الظفر دعم
السيد كمالك الاجدار اوغلو في جوله
الاعاده وادعوه كل من صوت لتحالف الجمهور
وتحالف الشعب وتحالفنا تحالف الاجداد
للتصويت له يوم الاحد المقبل
[موسيقى]